a bedroom at around 9 p.m. it's quiet
save for the rustle of the leaves in the
garden outside we're side by side each
absorbed in a different world one of us
might be in a submarine beneath the
Arctic ice floe the other is flitting
through the salons of eighteenth-century
Paris every so often our toes touch
momentarily but without raising much
notice we might briefly stretch your
hand to touch the nape of the partner's
neck before turning a page we can hear
our partner very lightly breathing there
is blessedly no need to say anything at
all and so it goes for what might be an
hour or more it's modest comfortable and
sweet and it is of course a pleasure
that our society is almost congenitally
prone not to notice or respect when
we're invited to picture what a
relationship might be for we imagine
typically colorful scenarios passionate
sex up against a wall a celebration of a
triumph at work heading for the airport
for a mini break the mutual exploration
of one another's souls and yet when the
true pleasures of long-term love are
assessed a rather different set of
images emerges far less dramatic but
also far more real and in their own way
gratifying the knowing sideways smile
our partner gives us in the presence of
a parent who's been tricky with us in
the past or watching a TV drama episode
by episode and bantering about the
characters and plot lines or sitting on
the floor sorting the socks after the
wash or the chat we have after the
friends who came for lunch if departed
or assembling a flat-pack bookcase and
realizing we've both got the
instructions entirely wrong and that
it's almost rather funny it's within
such a list of hidden pleasures that we
find the joy of reading in bed together
it represents in its own way a major
psychological skill there's not really
anyone else we could do this with if the
world were fairer we would seek partners
not just who can perform
spectacular sexual antics and look hot
in a bar but also those with whom we
could one day turn pages in silence to
read together is symbolic of being able
to share our true selves without shame
embarrassment or the need to perform we
are as we lie in bed together as we so
seldom are in the rest of life simply
accept it long-term relationships are
inevitably deeply complicated
enterprises too ambitious independent
authentic people cannot hope to join
their lives together without a huge
amount of friction and pain we tend to
be so much aware of the troubles we
sometimes take the peaceable moments for
granted failing to appreciate their
underlying achievement it may lack
glamour but being able to read and bed
together with someone is a major
milestone and a sign of deep affection
we may be doing better than we think we
hope you enjoyed this film for more from
the School of Life you can subscribe to
our Channel and take a look at our range
of products on our website
you